[Music]
in memory loss news oh I get so scared
of that submitted by what's cooking
good-looking oh oh gee one man the
Supreme Court takes the case of death
row inmate who forgot his crime wait
what mmm-hmm
what do you get amnesia something like
that I think I murder someone yeah I
just can't be man that would be my
defense that's a good defense hmm yes oh
this man he's 67 years old named Vernon
from Alabama
nobody gets named Vernon anymore that is
a 67 year old name that a died that's a
good name though it's a strong name I
like it or vermin so he was convicted of
fatally shooting a police officer in 18
I'm sorry
[ __ ] was a wall hold on a second yo this
got interesting
time track time travel these are early
for CT 9:30 stuck at 4,000 years old he
got his [ __ ] musket and blasted
[Laughter]
trumpet muskets - it's the one that has
a trumpet it was Colonel Sanders in the
kitchen with the musket let's ring the
murder weapon and the Gunpowder paipa
shoot you and they're putting the gun
Exhibit A
all right even for like those muskets -
like the amount of gunpowder tea it had
to be like the right amount yeah if it's
like too much it'll like implode and
[ __ ] yeah so back in 1985 he when there
was a police officer present and so he
was ordered to move out of his
girlfriends his former girlfriends home
and so as he was moving out I don't know
the details but he ended up shooting the
police officer twice in the back of the
head
oh [ __ ]
why is he so he he got put on death row
for that and so now like after all this
time he's he has suffered many strokes
that have wiped out his memory of
committing the crime Wow yeah and so now
they're looking into whether or not it
violates the Constitution's Eighth
Amendment against cruel and unusual
punishment so now he just thinks he's in
jail for no reason he just wakes up
everyday like why am i yeah that's deep
this is like I'm some black mirror [ __ ]
yeah
I'd say just keep a man yeah because it
doesn't change the type of person he is
it just erased that one memory yeah and
also too it doesn't alleviate the family
suffering from you know doesn't erase
the crime yeah and he also probably
doesn't even remember what life was like
not being in jail so like who's gonna
take care of them he's just gonna be
like a homeless guy he's peeing on oh
yeah he does have dementia yeah memory
imprisonment he's legally legally blind
he cannot walk on his own and he speaks
with a splurt a slur Explorer sorry San
Antonio Spurs I mean he's probably got
friends after all these years he's got
friends in there everything laughs he
remembers him yeah yeah and then that's
also like I'm sure there's plenty of
death row inmates that like live their
whole life on death row and then end up
getting dementia and don't remember a
lot of [ __ ] so it's like what are you
gonna do free them all yeah and then
they're gonna shoot me in the back and
then forget about it I'm surprised he
killed a police officer and they didn't
kill him like immediately yeah yeah it's
been like 30 years and therefore still
alive and he's finally getting a
sentence Danis a good point maybe he ran
away oh you mean like death row you know
what state is it that's 30 years I'm
surprised
oh mama sounds like one of those ago
Texas they'll fry your ass in a second
you're not on death row in Texas for
more than like three years well he got
on death row in 94 that's still a long
time 20 years yeah actually I don't know
Alabama seems like they're just chilling
like I feel
they don't like I feel like Alabama
doesn't move too fast kill them today no
not today
Alabama makes me think of sweet tea and
I forgot that you're a state sometimes
yeah oh yeah yeah like uh it's like her
mom oh yeah Wow what happened to you
Vermont yeah or like South Dakota and
North Dakota Connecticut Rhode Island
Rhode Island Rhode Island I feel like
III we always want to travel outside of
the United States but we should probably
explore this country so much since we
haven't even explored I feel like
there's the whole Middle area yeah
thanks for once like we are ready to pop
out kids and do road trips that's when I
want to explore the state my because for
now I wanted to travel internationally
it's easier kids just throw them in the
car yeah I like that plan to you we
could all go together
RV yeah yeah if you think I'm talking
about that and then I mentioned how we
talked about it I'm Jake enews and how
we were saying thank you that's how you
know you're getting old and you want to
buy an RV I been why I want come on
that's not you can't [ __ ] inside your
car shower yeah my grandpa used to keep
a pan under the seat wait what you've
got a [ __ ] a library Junior yeah what
does that everyone from our J has a pan
yes what okay that's a Virginia thing my
grandpa had a van okay it was like an 89
van it was like a Chevrolet or something
like that
and it had a TV in the back and a VCR oh
I know one of those yeah and so he had
like he had like mad [ __ ] in there for
long trips in so he put a pan under the
seat just in case stop that's right
didn't believe him pull it over I peed
in that pan nobody pulled over he just
kept going yeah
[Laughter]
oh no it was it was a cast-iron what did
your breakfast taste like after it just
like a little bit of heat okay the thing
that I don't get is like it's heavy as
hell right so you open the window and
you try to go like this and it might fly
back haha builds character joke I speak
to your Grandpa's for I'm just bought
this for you no I mean that's just
helmet driving with one arm throwing
[ __ ] out that we know it yes so when you
had real bacon without the pea flavor I
imagine you were pissed off weren't you
oh my god more importantly I do
specifically remember because you know
when you're a kid you remember certain
memories I do remember him throwing it
out the window and I know we were on the
freeway with the car behind you car
itself is probably drenched in piss cuz
then as soon as he throwing up I would
know the whole thing gets all drenched
builds character
gross yes I was keying bottles like I
never thought about this to an outlook
okay my mom would give me a little
bottle like this and in my little wiener
we'll go inside and just fill it up oh
yeah when I got too big I would fill it
up and I couldn't stop and it just kept
spilling and my mom got so mad oh
speaking of you know how you were
talking about you had a really pee right
and then you filled up a bottle or like
two bottles of just piss yeah right so I
was in the freeway and had a pee really
bad and I had an empty bottle so I had a
piss in it right you're right that [ __ ]
does fill up really really fast yeah you
can't appeal you don't know how much you
peoples are looking at a toilet exactly
it fills up this bottle a baby a bottle
the bottle I had was way bigger yeah but
it filled it up hold with to the top
yeah and I got lucky that's all I had I
had a little more I've been [ __ ]
yeah like gives like a sample of pee at
a doctor's office and you feel it yeah
you like you for a little bit out but
you still are like ashamed of like how
much pee you're giving so funny
I couldn't stop it'll hurt I just I just
pee oh my god
I got to do one of those oh no it does
take skin and just pee pee all over the
cups like close it and then I wipe it
for them body was I've been drinking so
much water it was like quite clear oh
nice
you know that's good goal just a little
tinge of color and it didn't smell so
bad because it was just like straight
water yeah also you're not taking
multivitamins that I know I'm taking
calcium in the the gummies ooh [ __ ] that
makes your pee neon it does and it
smells like I just means your body
didn't absorb at all yes I mean that's
vitamin so that's what vitamins do yep
hmm eat your vitamins people think
that's what they say yeah so back to
this dude so initially they said the
courts were saying like no no he can
still go through with the execution what
I like that no no no Brian but then they
but then his lawyers found out that the
the court-appointed psychologist who
evaluated him had a substance abuse
problem Oh had been suspended from his
practice and making his findings invalid
so this dude got saved again and so now
it's up to a Supreme Court yes
[ __ ] is lucky lawyers
here's Vernon he looks like a nice old
turtle oh he looks like you all Romero
he killed somebody seven there is not
one wrinkle on his face what the [ __ ]
black don't crack you it looks like OJ
to a little bit huh yeah oh yeah 60 70
it doesn't good that way he's a pretty
good hairline for 67 like I have more
wrinkles here my forehead in this guy I
like his glasses
ladies glasses yeah yeah you're lucky
right now I wonder if you used to dress
like Run DMC and try to kill no cop man
I need them I had those glasses I was
like in second grade and they had a
little brown tint to them I didn't know
they're so geeky I didn't know you had
transition glasses I don't know cuz I I
think I didn't really need glasses that
bad but then I saw like you know those
old like this go back
on the wall oh my glasses like that I
didn't know that looked like what they
want to call the [ __ ] all the second
grade so the third grade I have to
switch them out all that so people kept
picking on you know they did pick on me
because I'm just like a goofy kid but I
found out myself I'm like I don't think
I look very uh cool cool so that they
get some I have to get some modern-day
glasses I wasn't a [ __ ] sign there
the second grader is saying like mom I'm
not gonna get in the car I remember when
I felt I was unfuckable when all the
other kids were circumcised and I begged
my dad how come you didn't circumcise me
when I was a baby because all because
everybody when we eat when we go pee
together all of our my wieners a little
bit different from the other kids
and I was like girls aren't gonna want
to suck this anymore you knew that
well not suck it but I was just like I'm
not gonna get married because they're my
wieners different really I thought I had
a [ __ ] freak of nature at ear day
they told you were special though right
not different especially no they're just
like hell no we're not gonna do that to
you your dick is precious what like I'm
not cut like why would why would you cut
that and I'm like oh so now we know your
dad's not circumcised tell nah none of
us are it's so it's so interesting that
when you're a kid and you look at the
differences because when I saw my
cousin's dick and hadn't had no jacket
it was like huh wait what most guys like
actually end up getting like circumcised
it's like it completely depends on the
country where you're at were you from
there yeah I know somebody who got
circumcised after he was in my tech
Wando class and then he didn't come for
a couple of weeks and I was like where
did he go
and they said that he got a circumcision
I was like why like my god as an adult
you get a [ __ ] circumcision when
you're a oh my god did they put you
under I'm pretty sure they got a cut
that [ __ ] and do some other stuff with
it yeah but then you know you get like
no reason boners and they feel like
healing or scabbing up
just out of no reason just get a [ __ ]
boner rips all the scabs apart I still
found low with the uncircumcised dick so
it's okay
[Music]
[Music]